you guys answer some questions to me
about Islam I hear a lot of you know
different things people at Trump talking
about Islam and he puts a taco me
Christian tacos por la musica at
occasion video a Muslim man Kanako's
abroad dealership Asahi grab a beautiful
everything that is represented by TV is
a big big like what about this big
people here budget honeycomb greens a
piece here it's still the most art here
and it's really amazing Dawa carrying a
sharing you care for people you share
let's do this education that we can help
eliminate God willing this many
misconceptions people have the false
propaganda
and brothers here I are doing that let's
check in with them I wanna know about
Islam all right thank you can you guys
teach me can you guys answer some
questions to me about Islam I hear a lot
of you know different things people have
Trump talking about Islam and what do
you guys gotta say about that I have to
say this that Islam is very beautiful
thing everything that is represented by
TV is a big big lie if you want to learn
about Islam come talk with with a real
Muslim not with the people who are paid
to make you some look like something bad
Islam is very beautiful religion if you
don't try it you can know the media
women I heard you guys oppress women
gave a big a big generator for a woman
woman woman is a very special we can ask
you something if woman has rights to
show her but why doesn't she have
[Music]
covered her body which is part of
religion
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that should be spread around the press
right Nikki puts a Christian attack
whispered a massacre at occasion video a
Muslim and Yakuza Brazil s apostasy grab
cocoa spicy gravy Moni bless a true
honest pasados where work is version
here historian a Druze to service us dry
version was Dravid shed near modern-day
work - the Casa de the the the inane
cinema konista toward SEMA animatic we
just virtual shoe polish search rules to
Susan Swiss Genesis at roville I wanna
sue Buchla yes Donna tomorrow tune is no
[ __ ] nosotros was not alone a true when
I could sweat redness Nicki strong moral
IV depopulated not a Christian to deny
cert can your Belgrade oh poor poor girl
she knows no more than oppose name of a
cravat proposing distress vada is
Stephanie what Gulen is Bhushan is that
overran Kazuto that it iswe
was worried a rich pretty G Star beer
economy Nevada marchers drew go Donna
Kasia Stan it yesterday an Athena de
vacaciones cross goal academia put a
piercing Kadima not caduceus wavy do not
add an Isetta motive test nick farmer
not countable is illegal Keveza Motoko
hula hooped atoll eco pretty another
sister lucky terrorists in already eat
toffee sauce too obstinate privilege the
motor needs and Nashville's various
Amish carotene is a macaque Avenger many
already a large near below the video
channel
they will Co one equipo connect a colony
punish them up America's our mission
caucus a tourniquet is Araucana
yesterday was not Jeanne Marie short
windows
although they noticed him a time Naima
Naima name on a doctor knows in 3d
Ramallah father not Jana mr. Krakow
Poznan is not sick Oh gotcha pre-budget
académica Onaga Coelho she of tinea
Queen Iike the Nativity double more
chronic an IGBT dobara tots kinetic
energy between the Daubert reckon
apostle now she on Australia veggies are
billed as a survey trevecca kovachev
almost not a McDonough auto purchaser as
Westie the chibita element at SIA firk
Ellison
every religion has a jihad that's a
battle that is attacking you jihad in
his first place is fight against
yourself against your your your soul for
example if I'm smoking cigarettes and if
I want to throw that away
that's my jihad if I'm drinking the
alcohol and I want to throw out the
hallway I don't want to do anymore this
jihad with my soul if I'm dead too
towards my parents and I have to correct
that to this relationship with my
friends it's my jihad never so jihad on
media crews that is just like a war fire
fighting in a no-no
jihad is the purpose fight against
yourself because in Quran Allah says if
you kill one innocent man it's like that
you kill all of humanity if you say one
man it's like that you save all humanity
so jihad on TV is represented very bad
jihad is not only fighting against your
enemy ok if
if someone attacks you it's your natural
easy that you will defend yourself but
jihad is also like my brother said if
you guard against your soul our soul has
unique means towards women towards
alcohol to earth cigarettes and a lot of
other stuff maybe that isn't good for
your body so jihad isn't only fighting
against your enemy it's only fighting
its accept only fight you with your soul
so basically you struggle and strive we
got some misconceptions out of the way
all right these are the kind of
questions that you guys can you know
going to a mosque and ask or if you find
a you know poof dower Center you know
that you can go in educational center
okay now we got those out of the way
first one wants to know like what you
know you know I'm kind of empty inside
and I'm trying to figure out what's the
purpose of life what what solutions give
me to that direction first first in the
Prophet that Allah revealed to the
Prophet Muhammad sallallahu alayhi wa
sallam was it sort of a smear of
becoming and being a father read in the
name of the Lord who creates so the
advice I would give to someone who is
empty inside is to read Quran you'll
find everything there I can swear that
everyone who reads Quran will find the
truth over there you'll feel fulfilled
insides he'll be happy and everything
because everything is explained in Quran
every little thing you can imagine if it
is explained in Quran and then there is
the hadith of the Prophet Muhammad
sallallahu alayhi wa sallam you can find
it on the internet everywhere you can
read you have it in the books and that
that is the most beautiful thing again I
can ever explain to anyone the hadith of
the prophet muhammad
sallallahoalyhiwasallam but first thing
you have to do is read the Quran read
the Quran don't judge the Quran reading
because could unsmooth and nice mother
News magnate him it is the smartest is
it from the Lord of the Worlds you have
to read that and you will understand
everything protein Hamed saw what he was
selling what is the last prophet the
last prophet in the world we have the
first prophet nooh alehissalaam first
prophet prophet mohammed salameh the law
is the last prophet
he's how you say feel seal the prophecy
and Quran is the last reveal of God of
the Lord of the world
he wasn't like he was sent by the Lord
to mercy to all the into all the world
he was sent to the desert to to be shown
by our Creator what is the best way to
live life and we have true through his
examples of living treating other people
treating his enemies he didn't he didn't
allow in Wars to be killed to kill any
innocent man not to kill all people not
to killed women especially not to kill
Jesus you know I love Jesus I don't need
what do you say we love Jesus too is
also messenger of allah well there is a
difference between between religions
because Christians some of them who
believe the Jesus peace be upon me is is
God himself but Islam reveals that he is
the Prophet he is the Prophet just like
a Muhammad but he was six six nine eight
six six hundred years six hundred years
before and he was also a prophet he also
gave way of life and Muhammad is the
seal for prophecies because people left
Jesus is true through studies and left
what he taught them they again started
worshipping statues and and then stuff
like that so Quran confirmed
because even in the Quran Quran Allah
says they did not kill him or cursed by
him but God took him to himself so he's
not dead he's not crucified he he will
come again before the Judgment Day and
the earth and that's also said in the
Bible that he will come back but but
main thing to know is that he's not a
god
you know Quran is a real 1,400 years ago
and by today if you do if you take Quran
from Australia and you took her on for
Germany the Quran is the same not not
the single verse is changed Quran in
Australia is the same Quran that is in
Germany if we take all the books all the
religious books away from the earth and
falling in the sea destroy them all all
all of them the book tomorrow that would
get on a desk is the Quran because we
have so many people that memorize the
hold on in their minds that are copies
so tomorrow that would be how can how
can someone know that Jesus or God
wasn't written by Muhammad but it was
really from the crater now can I be sure
about the leaning what do you believe
is the world so now we have many many
versions of the Bible that has been
changed over time you do have the Word
of God in the but she also had the word
of historian have the word of prophets
you have the word of people we don't
even know who's writing but that's not
like the cause people had this
misconception think of it the Bible
which is you know many books we don't
even know where they come here from but
the Quran is unlike yeah not a single
word it changed in every country in the
world everywhere it was a real 400 years
1400 years ago the same word that was
written in 1400 years ago it's still in
the Quran the other single words was
changed not a single and what what's the
what's the main theme you tell people so
wants to know the theme what's the main
message living in one God
leaving one there's only one God no god
but him yes tell me
that's the main thing in
because that's the main thing of Islam
believing in one God and not associating
anything with you are something with him
that's what Islam what's the number one
question here in mostar about that you
guys get half on people
you get a lot of creations a lot of
Serbians
even Muslims we're not practicing people
people will come from a communist
background is what what are some of the
questions that you got top three
questions that you get first of all that
we all they're all judging each one by
media and that's the main problem is
they're all asking questions just like
you are jihad and this and that and the
Muslims in India are not praying and
stuff they call themselves Muslims but
they traditional believing yeah yeah not
the original believing that Muhammad
sallallaahu came with they have their
own tradition believing that was here
maybe two or three hundred years ago and
they are stuck sticking with them but
the main question is about jihad when I
got when I got into some three or four
years ago my parents were afraid that I
will go I will go to work for example
mom when I started growing beard a photo
something like this but when I changed
my approach to them they love Islam and
now they're praying today for example
because you are you're calling people to
Islam with your attitude with your with
your behavior and when they see that
you're good like that they will accept
that but if I'm always angry angry they
will think everyone is like that so for
example if I approach you for example
take this take this take this you will
think that Islam is like that but we are
the missionaries of Islam every one of
us which it actually is
breathing that's some great advice why
not you read you read every other book
why can't you read a book that is
telling you it's from the creator and
has a test in it saying if you think
it's from other than God do this
dissonance do XY and Z try to prove it
wrong which you can
try at least pick it up pick up the book
and read it tell us do you have a lot of
because we're in Bosnia hearing that I
know some operations and Serbians or
Christian have you had an Islamist for
everyone yet so have you had many of
them also accept Islam for example I'm
working with the Christians and when I
came there the need for time that now
over a year and now they are asking me
questions just like you and explain to
them and they they're kind of like it's
wrong no they don't love it they don't
worship it but they kind of like it now
so they're they change your opinion of
basically those apple hi I presented
Islam but there are a lot of people that
are accepting for example that are
searching for something to fulfill their
soul and everything very every book
every when it comes to the Quran when
they get it why should we the Quran
they're like no caranas jihad it's war
oppression of women but when they really
did they punish me and I know a lot of
know Islam accepted Islam because Quran
was the last they read the attention of
the Bible main advice for people who is
not in Islam or doesn't know anything
about son don't trust media media is a
big fat lie about the son and I'm going
the world everywhere if you want to know
the real truth about some talk to a real
Muslim go to reasoning drink green
coffee with with a real Muslim and he
will show you because
the best of you are the one for best
behavior so we are representing the song
with our behavior well it's a nice
talking with you guys one more question
so if someone is Serbian yep a Croatian
and he believes but you worship the
creator of Jesus and they want to be a
Muslim one word submitted what's a
Muslim means one who has submitted
themselves entirely to God
and now religious Croatian is not a
religion we have Christianity we have
Islam they can be serving but the
emotion they can be Croatian but be
emotionalism you are Muslim you only
live in England that's that that's I
know a lot of crows it yes that live in
Croatia I know a lot of people from
Serbia that are Muslim and live in
Serbia so living in any other country
doesn't change the fact if you want to
be a Muslim you can be muscle no one can
stop you by that so people are there and
most are working they hook up and learn
some more information or they can find
you guys here yes here today and we have
a host of a page
WWE WWE not Monaco and you can find
everything so if you want to know this
LOM talk to we're Muslim read the Quran
and trust me this in Quran you will see
that the Lord in advance says that this
is a book that there is no mistake in
every other book you will see that the
writer says if there is any mistake I am
really sorry but in Quran o in Quran the
Lord says this is the book that there is
no doubt in it also one thing I can
recommend to everyone if they don't want
to read it on YouTube you can see all
right so we're here we're talking to
somebody here give me some showers
sharing they care for this information
else we learn one thing that don't
believe the hype the false propaganda -
that sounds here come on I'm gonna whoop
your mind you're smart enough keep your
mind open has to function properly
Bridgette function probably has to be
like a parity keep it open and go and
meet the Muslims connect with anyone and
really find out what this mom is about
and I ask that questions what's the main
theme of the Quran what's the purpose of
life in there it's so straightforward
not this nebulous thing where you know
just philosophy worship the Creator not
the creation live life in a way that's
pleasing to your Creator so then you'll
be successful when you meet your Creator
we're here in Bosnia mostar I wanna know
about Islam give them doubt yes yes so
now he's asking me here because I
recognized some words Dawa and sounds so
much
cretins loan for yet all right yeah it
was kind of a test or something I'm just
about to ask you I was just about to ask
you
holy Sh oh yeah yeah yes we follow
certain moves one what submits the will
of Gus I probably tried my best every
day to submit myself to the one who
created this creation who created the
heaven on earth in English God in Arabic
Allah and Aramaic the language Jesus
both Allah ha the question oh what's
your name my name you know you know all
right we got vino here thank you very
much last night watch me I'll bless you
to continue on the wonderful work well
this is our gift
you